many questions we should be asking
themselves they should ask themselves
Who am I what do I want what's my
purpose what's my passion what's the
contribution i want to make to the world
what are my peak experiences and why
what are my unique talents how do i
express them how do i use them to
service the needs of my fellow human
beings who are my heroes in history in
mythology and religion and why in other
words what are the archetypal stories
that stimulate my imagination and make
me aspire to an idealist vision what are
the qualities I look for in a good
friend what are the qualities are
expressed in my relationships I think if
you ask these questions then somehow
nature conspires to move you into the
answers right now in my stage of life is
how can I make a difference without
thinking about myself
to every person Deepak Chopra's a
reflection of where they are in their
own evolution you know there's a form of
roomies has defined me and labeled me
and you'll starve yourself of yourself
nail me down in a box with cord words
and that box would be a coffin because I
don't know who I am or maybe I'm your
own voice reflecting of the world